I want to take a couple of minutes to
tell you about one of our partners
atomic wallet which you can check out at
atomic wallet dot IO I've put the link
right below the video
atomic wallet is a noncustodial
cryptocurrency wallet for all major
platforms it's what I use to store my
crypto you can use it to store a
mile-long list of different Kryptos
including the most popular ones bitcoin
litecoin aetherium ripple you can use it
on Windows Mac Linux iOS and Android so
you can take it anywhere you go
regardless of what operating system you
use and there's some really big names in
the crypto space that use in love atomic
wallet it has a four and a half star
rating on Trustpilot as well as both the
Android and iOS app stores and the keys
you use to access your crypto are
encrypted and do not leave your device
and that's what I mean when I say it's a
noncustodial wallet only you have full
access to your crypto not a tonic wallet
as a company all of the wallets
functions are fully anonymous they don't
know who you are you open the app you
get a 12 word backup phrase you'll see
it supports 40 blockchains and any
tokens on the exchange there are a ton
of pairs the exchange is instant and
anonymous the buy crypto function is
supported worldwide and has a ten to
thirty minute delivery and you can see
all of your transactions in one history
list the mobile app is great it's even
compatible with face ID you can benefit
from their loyalty program that uses
their native token called AWC an atomic
wallet also has 24/7 online support
they're ready to help you anytime
check out atomic wallet has a ton of
useful features pretty much anything you
would want in a crypto wallet
experienced crypto holders love it but
it's ultimately really simple to use
even if you don't have much experience
with crypto currency if you've been
looking for a way to get into crypto for
the first time this is the perfect way
to do it go download atomic wallet for
desktop or mobile play around with it
you'll see why it's gotten so many
positive reviews and why so many people
use it and I've put a link right
underneath this video